Israel Isel you
[Applause]
can't people are occupied when people
are
[Music]
[Applause]
occupied now those scenes remind us that
here in the United States there are Lord
knows how many people tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands more people who
truly believe that Hamas is getting a
bad rap
they're Freedom Fighters joining me now
is Natalie Sandi just over two weeks ago
she spent hours fleeing the scene of
that music festival Massacre Natalie
thank you for sharing your story tonight
now you've seen these protests in
America the chance of supporting the
intifa given what you've been through
what's your
takeaway as if it wasn't enough to have
to go through that attack in Israel to
come back to New York that's been my
home my entire life and to see all these
protests and to see people calling for
the genocide of the Jews and to see so
many misinformed people in the streets
thinking that Hamas is for the
Palestinian people hamas's agenda is to
free
Palestine it makes me sad and honestly a
little scared now uh I read somewhere
that you felt like you were
safer in the Middle East or in Israel
than at moments here in the United
States explain that
as someone who comes from a family my
parents my father is
Iranian they fled Iran they fled
persecution and either went to the US or
Israel Israel after the Holocaust was
given back to the Jewish people as their
home and for a long time a lot of Jews
called the US their
home but recently I I fear the Lone Wolf
attacks that are happening here I I did
go through a very serious trauma and
attack in Israel but I feel more
protected here than I feel in Israel
than I feel here at the moment I don't
feel that enough people are taking these
protests and these Lone Wolf attacks
seriously the anti-Semitism on college
campuses is something that we've been
reporting on for years the radicalism
the it's embedded with anti-americanism
as well but it's it's been it's been
encouraged nurtured and I think fed by a
lot of big corporations that wrote
checks to colleges and universities over
the years with kind of a blind eye um
speak to that for a moment given the
scenes at some of our most prestigious
schools obviously I can see
that though a lot of these people at the
protests are quote unquote well-educated
people from very big universities
they're obviously very much
misinformed it's unfortunate that
that a lot of people just believe
whatever they read online for example
after the headline that the IDF had sent
that rocket towards the hospital in Gaza
and all these news channels
automatically broadcasted that everyone
saw how many protests broke out against
Israel but once some of them corrected
themselves and stated that it was the
Islamic Jihad that sent that rocket I
didn't see any protests against the
Islamic Jihad god well we also had
sitting congressmen and women for
refusing to correct themselves and and
and then in a way egging the protesters
on this is part of the reason why I feel
unsafe is because I'm seeing a lot of
patterns that we saw before the
Holocaust part of what happened before
the Holocaust was a lot of f fake news
and propaganda against the Jews and I'm
seeing that today as well denial yeah
denial of what the actual truth is what
we're seeing on the ground Natalie thank
you for speaking out we really really
appreciate it hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else